there's a lot to digest during the final
hours of resident evil village
a lot of which completely
re-contextualizes resident evil 7
and even the founding of umbrella itself
making several connections across
the entire franchise so let's get into
the nitty-gritty of all this and explain
exactly what went down and the ripple
effect it has on the rest of the series
and yes this is a spoiler loaded video
so if you haven't finished resident evil
village yet leave now
go finish it and then come back you've
been warned
okay throughout the game you'll see
allusions to the umbrella corporation's
logo
but what does the strange eastern
european village have to do with the
evil company responsible for the
creation of the t-virus
the destruction of raccoon city and the
years of monster-based
bio-terrorism that have gripped the
resident evil world ever since
what happened thankfully these questions
are answered
let's start with where ethan winters
meets up with chris redfield again
after all it's chris that kicked off all
these shenanigans
first some context ethan and chris have
a history
it was chris in a strike force from the
bioterrorism security assessment
alliance or
bsaa that ultimately rescued ethan
and mia from the baker house at the end
of resident evil 7. in the three years
between seven and village chris and the
bsaa
have put ethan and mia in hiding in
europe to avoid the crime syndicate that
was behind the incident
called the connections when you finally
find chris and heisenberg's factory
you get the full scoop on what's been
happening first chris has been
investigating the connections all this
time
the shadowy group originally used a
strange
mold called the muta my seat to create
evelyn a young girl
who was also a bioweapon evelyn was
capable of creating the mold from re7
that made people into super regenerative
near unkillable monsters in which
allowed evelyn to control their minds
mia secretly worked with the connections
and was tasked with playing caretaker
bodyguard and possibly executioner to
evelyn
when the connections were moving evelyn
by ship she escaped and destroyed it
causing it to wash up in the bayou near
the bakers's house
when jack baker found the shipwreck and
evelyn inside she infected them
and the rest of his family jack also
found mia the only other survivor
and she was infected too so the
connections have been looking for mia
and ethan who were seemingly cured of
their
mutamyc infections in resident evil 7.
and that's why chris had them in hiding
but when me and ethan had a baby
they drew the intention of mother
miranda the chief boss of resident evil
village
miranda wanted the baby for her own ants
about a hundred years before the events
of the game miranda lost her daughter
eva to the spanish flu and becoming
despondent
wandered into a cave beneath the village
to await death
there she discovered the original source
of the muta my seat mold
the mega my seat miranda gained
regenerative abilities that staved off
aging and illness and eventually
cultivated the power to rearrange her
own cells
to become a shapeshifter miranda can
make herself wings or
any other number of gross limbs she can
also completely change her appearance to
mimic
any other person miranda spent years
studying
the mega my seat to unlock its full
potential she became a full-on scientist
and when you find her secret layer you
find pictures to that end
she even worked with other scientists
and researchers and functioned as a
teacher as a part of her legitimate
non-monster life sometime around 1951
she worked with the
then medical student oswell spencer to
do
research on using separate organisms to
mutate humans
namely the mega myc mold you might
remember spencer is one of the three
founders of the umbrella corporation
spencer in fact
was miranda's student and held her in
high regard
spencer was fascinated by miranda's idea
that the mold could be used to
completely alter people
but the teacher and student had
different goals miranda wanted to use
her theories to resurrect her dead
daughter
spencer wanted to transform all of
humanity and remake it in his own image
and
a much more eugenicist kind of nazi-like
approach
he decided the mold wasn't contagious
enough to do that
but thought a virus might be so spencer
and miranda parted ways spencer and his
pals went on to discover the
stairway to the sunflower in africa
which is first seen in resident evil 5.
and that's what he and his umbrella
co-founders would use to eventually
create the undeadifying
t virus from the original resident evil
but spencer looked back fondly at his
time with miranda and even used the
octagonal shape
seen around the village as inspiration
for the umbrella logo
so that's why the logo seems to appear
all around the village
miranda inspired spencer to start the
research
that would lead to the t virus and he
stole his company logo from local art
what a bastard okay let's move on to
miranda's goals and what she's been
trying to accomplish
throughout her research miranda has been
working to try to change
people into something else because she
specifically wants to bring her dead
daughter back
from the dead miranda thinks she can do
that because
of the nature of the mega my seat which
apparently works like
a giant hard drive yes a giant
hard drive it breaks down and absorbs
the consciousness
of anyone who is infected with the mold
their minds are basically stored within
the mega mystere colony miranda thinks
she can use the mole to literally bring
her daughter back to life
because her daughter is a part of the
mold and so
still alive inside of it after
umbrella's fall following resident evil
2
miranda met and worked with the
connections she gave them a part of the
mega micey and
ava's dna in hopes that the organization
could help resurrect her daughter
miranda worked with the research team
and they eventually created
evelyn but evelyn was an ava miranda
deemed the whole thing of failure and
bailed on the connections returning to
her work
in the village what miranda decided she
needs is a body for her daughter to
inhabit
over the years miranda has been
experimenting on people of the village
mixing the mold with a strange
fetus-like looking parasite called
a cadu to transform them as we saw in
resident evil 7
not everyone takes well to the mold some
people are killed by it
others turn into mindless monsters when
the kadu affects you badly
you churn into a lichen because that
makes any sense
the four lords you meet in resident evil
village are can do experiments that
turned out better
heisenberg was the best version and had
the most power
followed by lady dimitresk who became a
vampire because of a genetic disorder
she needs to constantly eat human flesh
and blood
to maintain her regenerative powers then
dana benaviento
and finally maru each of these people
took to kadu
better than most but none was quite
perfect
and miranda wants someone who's perfect
because that person will be the vessel
she uploads her daughter into
when miranda learns about rose ethan and
mia's daughter
she decides that this will be the
perfect person to use
as her daughter's vessel so she captures
mia then uses her shapeshifter powers
to impersonate her at ethan's house
that's why ethan felt mia was acting so
weird at the beginning of village
he was actually talking to miranda who
didn't really know about the events with
the bakers and
other things about mia but chris was on
to miranda somehow anyway
he and his bsaa special forces team the
hound wolf squad
busted into ethan's house and blasted
miranda mia with
bullets at the start of the game
thinking they'd killed miranda who still
looked like mia but
dead they threw the body ethan and rose
into a van to get them out of there
but miranda was only playing dead she
revived the van
killed everyone but the unconscious
ethan
and kidnap rose while ethan is wandering
the village during the game
chris and the hound wolf squad are
infiltrating it they're searching for
rose
trying to uncover miranda's whole deal
and also looking for evidence about the
connections
which are still at large three years
after the baker incident
as we learned from chris's files and
computer though they never do find
anything about the crime syndicate those
folks are
long gone but why does miranda want
rose that's related to one other big
twist of the game
ethan is actually a mold monster
just like the baker's surprise he was
killed and regenerated way
back near the start of resident evil 7.
when he was first captured by jack baker
in resident evil 7
ethan was forced to eat the gross meat
the family had at their dinner
he wasn't the first this ransom meat was
the means by which the bakers and evelyn
infected new members of their family
with the mold
with ethan the mole took hold extremely
well
just like the bakers that's why ethan
can withstand
so much punishment in resident evil 7
including
losing his hand and then just stapling
it back on like nothing happened
he has mold-based regenerative powers
it's also why he's so damn hard to kill
in resident evil village
ethan and mia got cured of their mold
infections to some degree after evelyn
was killed but clearly
it never really went away thus ethan has
been some kind of
mold human hybrid ever since and that
means that rose is
also some kind of mold of a human hybrid
when heisenberg talks about wanting to
use rose's power
this is why she's the successful version
of what the connections we're trying to
create with evelyn
she's the ultimate weapon this can't be
your daughter's essence is still intact
her powers are truly unique
this is also why miranda is able to
crystallize rose
break her into pieces and put her into
those weird flasks
she's not a regular human being and her
mold properties mean she can survive the
process
while ethan is fighting to save rose we
also find out from heisenberg that
miranda is
essentially auditioning him to be her
right hand man
she wants him to wipe out her other
children to prove how strong he is
while also eliminating any threat from
the weaker lords
heisenberg is after all literally
building an
army for a rebellion of course ethan
doesn't go for it and defeats miranda in
the final battle
but at this point it seems that ethan
has suffered too much to survive
even with mold powers as we've seen with
all the other mold people he's killed
the regenerative powers
aren't infinite so ethan sacrifices
himself to destroy the mega my seat
once and for all
what have you done he's gone except
of course for one thing so this last
item is a
bit more cryptic but at the very end of
village we get one last scene
this one skips ahead in time a
significant amount to find rose as a
teenager or
young adult she takes a bus to visit her
father's secret grave before a secret
service looking guy
finds her seemingly a member of the
hound wolf squad
we quickly get the impression that rose
is working with chris redfield and his
special force pails to fight monsters
rose mentions her tests and immediately
after that spots the wolfhound with
soldier muttering
speak of the devil that suggests the
tests aren't related to school but some
kind of bsaa related training
from what we can tell rose is an ally of
the wolf hound squad
but they're also clearly keeping an eye
on her
when the trooper mockingly refers to
rose as evelyn you know
a living mold weapon in the form of a
kid rosemary reacts in something of a
threatening way at the insult you're
needed
evelyn don't you ever
call me that again oh it's just a joke
rose
so we can assume that rosemary has the
mold powers miranda and heisenberg
expected
but she is using them to work with chris
on his
ongoing anti-bioterrorism mission we
then hear a quick bit of conversation
over a guards radio in which he tells a
distant
sniper not to take a shot at the kid
so how wolf squad is standing ready to
take rose down if she turns out to be an
evil mold monster instead of a good mold
monster
person rose's comments about evelyn and
ethan two people she couldn't possibly
have ever known
also seemed to play into what miranda
said about the mega micey
this might be a stretch since rosemary's
comments are a bit cryptic but
if the mega micey acted as the hard
drive-like storage for the personalities
of all the people who are infected by it
then
rose may actually know them both they
and everyone else might actually be a
literal part of her
that seemed to be what was going on in
the scene in which evelyn reveals to
ethan his true
nature as a mold man through the mega my
seat
evelyn lives on and thus was able to
communicate with ethan
a similar scene played out at the end of
resident evil 7 when jack baker was able
to communicate with ethan
despite being you know dead and that
would also explain rosa's intense
reaction to being called evelyn
she may feel the influence of both
evelyn and her father pulling her in
different directions
in any event rosemary's status as a
human bioweapon
working with and under the protection of
pseudo-imprisonment
of hound wolf squad looks to be the
lead-in for the next resident evil
as village tells us at the end credits
the father story
is now done but there's still
many unanswered questions first there's
the question of what else miranda got up
to during her hundred years of
experimentation
the photos of her and oswald spencer
suggest the two were working on some
kind of cold weather excavation
in the 1950s before spencer began his
umbrella work
the photos aren't clear but what they
were looking for in that snowy locale
could be mold related if there's more
mold out there
what was miranda looking for and what
did she and spencer find
there's also the question of the bsaa
inclusion that happens at the end of the
game when chris and hound wolf squad go
after miranda themselves
the bsaa set its own soldiers separate
from
chris's team to the village to attack
miranda
the question is why and why wouldn't
chris and his pales know about it
k9 i want to know what the hell bsaa is
doing here
find out what you can what's more at the
very end of the game one of chris's team
remarks that the bsaa
soldiers aren't soldiers at all they're
bioweapons
with a mask off the bsaa soldier's body
they're investigating looks more like a
zombie or umbrella-era tyrant creature
that's all together weird since the bsaa
is supposed to be fighting bioterrorism
but the psaa
has had strange ties to the evil doers
before
in the canon cgi animated movie resident
evil degeneration
the pharmaceutical company funding the
bsaa tri-cell is actually doing its own
umbrella-like monster research
before they're exposed and brought down
there's also blue umbrella an
organization created out of the remnants
of evil umbrella
but with the aim of stopping bioweapon
research and bioterrorism
chris doesn't trust these folks either
but was cooperating with them during the
ending of resident evil 7 when he saved
mia and ethan
so what's their deal finally the
post-credits scene of village ends on a
strange
image the hound wolf car drives off from
the cemetery and in the distance
we see a lone figure walking down the
dirt road toward it
eventually the figure in the car seemed
to meet and the car seemingly stops as
the figure approaches
but then the scene just ends was the
figure important
why did the car stop is that a tease of
something more or just a weird red
herring in the final seconds of resident
evil village
seems like we might be waiting a bit to
find out those answers
then again capcom added a lot of context
to resident evil 7 through dlc
including not a hero the episode that
starred chris redfield and fleshed out
the ending of that story
so maybe more context is on the way and
we won't have to wait five years for a
new resident evil game to tie all the
threads up
so just in case this franchise's lore
wasn't complicated enough
then well now you have this if you're
interested in more convoluted resident
evil backstory then please be sure to
check out our complete
resident evil timeline explained link in
the description below
okay hope this cleared something up for
you
thanks for watching see you later
[Music]
you